today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
absolutely crazy news broke yesterday
former white house chief strategist to
donald trump steve
bannon was arrested and indicted on
multiple
charges for defrauding thousands of
donors
through those crazy bill we build the
wall
initiatives that he was a part of and it
was
bannon and three other people indicted
in a federal investigation in the
southern district of new york
what prosecutors say went down is that
bannon and three others defrauded donors
by raising more than 25 million bucks to
build a wall along the southern
border of the united states and that a
bunch of the money was used for personal
gain
there there are so many stories here
remember when this was happening
when there was this idea that hey if
trump can't get the money from the libs
or the dems then we'll just raise the
money privately
turns out that steve bannon was involved
in one of those schemes at the time
i said who's stupid enough to donate to
this to think that this is a project
that individuals can actually do
and if they did donate to it is it so
stupid that they deserve
what's coming to them which is to lose
their money but clearly this is a scam
and we were right but the scam
is one that steve bannon is involved in
to the tune of 25 million dollars
the other people indicted inclu include
that guy brian
colfage who's the guy we reported on
when this money was actually being
raised
and of course now the distancing with
steve bannon by some will start
trump i'm sure will say this is very
unfair
these were people looking to do
something that the dems didn't want to
do they were doing a good thing raising
money for the wall of course that's not
what at what's at issue
what's that issue uh is that uh it is
was allegedly a money laundering wire
fraud scheme
and there there was this funny picture
over the weekend
of steve bannon being interviewed on fox
news and looking really haggard and a
lot of people were laughing about it and
commenting on it
maybe he knew this was coming and that's
why his appearance was so bizarre and
outrageous and federal prosecutors have
a lot of details here
they say that when donors were donating
to this project they were assured
100 of the money we raised will go to
build the wall
and i could tell that wasn't true many
of you could tell that wasn't true
anybody with any common sense could tell
they're not using 25 million to build
the wall
people started writing to brian colfidge
and uh it started to get
weird and then it turns out that these
guys were
profiting from this profiting from and
and
and again i sort of said if you donate
to this you're so stupid you deserve to
lose your money
still criminality is alleged here and so
if there are criminals and they can be
proven to be criminals they should be
prosecuted
morally maybe there's a different
argument to be made but
certainly there should be prosecution
and we're talking about
these individuals taking hundreds of
thousands of dollars from the donations
essentially creating
uh really like their own slush fund in a
sense
and now the pr will start and now we are
going to see this turned into yet
another one of these
political witch hunts as many claim that
the trump investigations have been and
the trump impeachment
have been but don't be confused if it
smells like a duck
and it walks like a duck and it sounds
like a duck it's often a duck
uh or someone pretending to be a duck
and in this case
uh this was all of the above and more
to sort of uh go to the end of the
analogies and metaphors but
is anybody if anybody is truly surprised
by this i would be shocked
but that's the latest steve bannon
indicted
are we going to hear bannon i don't
remember bannon was he like an intern
maybe for a brief period in 2015 no this
guy was on the national security council
at one point or at least he sat in the
meetings
this is serious and they're going to
pretend it's not but this is absolutely
outrageous
speaking of embarrassment and shame a
new poll confirms
what should obviously be the case and
yet in america
when 60 million people voted for donald
trump
it would be wrong to assume that what
makes sense
will be most americans are embarrassed
however by the trump coronavirus
response
according to a new ssrs poll so
not only are we the laughingstock of the
world
and the pity of the world we are also
embarrassed which is good we should be
the right emotion is to be embarrassed
by what we've done
on this planet as far as coronavirus is
concerned so a few notes from this poll
disapproval of trump's handling of the
virus is up to 58 percent
great but how does 42 percent of the
country think trump did a good job on
the virus
that's a problem 8 in 10 americans are
angry about the response and 51
are very angry well people should be
angry but that's deceptive
because some people are angry because of
how bad the response has been
while some people are angry that they
have to wear masks so that one is a
little bit less clear
but then the headline seven in ten
americans are embarrassed by the
response
and we should be embarrassed because
it's been embarrassing and now there are
also
two important indicators in this poll
about when things should start to return
to normal
now 57 percent of americans say schools
should not open for in-person classes in
the fall some have already opened
but that's not a huge majority anyway
only 57
say keep schools closed in the fall for
in person do remote
for sports 49 of americans say
there should not be in-person sports 45
percent of americans say
there should be in-person sports these
are really depressing numbers
even with this polarized a country you
would think
you would hope that almost everyone
would realize
guys this is embarrassing obviously
we're not in a position to open schools
right now it's not about
never open them it's about let's just do
remote for one more semester and then
hopefully we'll have a vaccine and
better treatments and things can start
to normalize
in early 2021. no embarrassing
schools shouldn't yet open but that's
not
what most people uh or what nearly half
of americans believe
now don't forget when you look at these
numbers
we talked about this yesterday on the
show somewhere between
40 and 50 of this country doesn't even
plan to get the vaccine which will make
herd immunity impossible
in any kind of short to medium term so
the real headlines here are reversed
right
instead of wow 70 percent of americans
embarrassed by trump's coronavirus
response
the red alert is whoa 30 of americans
aren't embarrassed by trump's
coronavirus response that's where the
focus
should be that's about 100 million
people if you include
you know out of the full population
which includes kids but fine
with adults it would be some smaller
number than that 20
of americans aren't angry about trump's
coronavirus response
what that's like 60 million people oh
wait
trump got about 60 million votes in
2016. now
if we go back to embarrassment for a
second
yeah we should be embarrassed about
trump's response
to coronavirus and i am but we should be
just as embarrassed
by the reactions and the behavior of a
huge portion of the country's people
i've said before when trump leaves we
still have 60 million trumpists to deal
with
we've seen protests against mask wearing
we've seen protests against social
distancing guidelines
we've seen people losing their minds in
costcos and walmarts about
liberty and freedom over wearing a mask
and
trying to stop the spread of a virus
conspiracy theories
about dr anthony fauci to the point
where he needs security and his
daughters need security bill gates
wants to microchip you it is
embarrassing
what trump has done but it's doubly
embarrassing when we look
not at trump himself but at his
administration's response
at the people around him and at our
fellow americans
at some point we're going to be past
this and we'll be able to do a
post-mortem
and we will need to include in our
analysis
not just an analysis of what trump did
and didn't do
not just an analysis of what the trump
administration did and didn't do
but we're going to need to do an
analysis of the 60 million people
who voted once for this guy and are
going to vote for him a second time
hopefully it won't be enough to give him
another four years and we have to
contend with them
for a very long time and i've not gotten
any good answers to this i've now talked
about this for a couple of weeks
and the main point is if trump wins he's
going to do it with 65
66 67 million voters if trump loses he's
going to lose with
60 to 63 million voters maybe even 64
million voters
even if he loses we have 60 something
million trumpists in the
in this country they're on school boards
they are working in stores that you go
to
they are maybe your family they are
maybe your relatives your friends
whatever
what do we do about that because we as a
country are not really going to be able
to advance
until we do something to weed out the
ideology that got 60 million plus people
to vote
for trump not once but no doubt twice uh
or we have to figure out a way to make
progress
around them or despite them and i don't
know what the answer is
i'm always open to hearing ideas from
you
sunday is the 15th anniversary
of the david pakman show august 23rd i
still remember that first show
it was pretty bad but to commemorate the
15th anniversary on sunday
we'll be doing a one-day huge membership
special the goal
being to bring in more new members
this month than ever before if you'd
like to be notified
about this great special it's really
really good it's actually
it is by far the biggest uh uh special
we've run this year
really ever i would say um and from the
standpoint of dollars
okay so all you need to do to be
notified on sunday
is get on my newsletter my mailing list
you go to davidpakman.com top
right of the page you will see a place
to just type in your email that's all
you have to do
and then sunday you will be notified
let's go to a quick break make sure
you're following me
on twitter at d pacman i want to hear
what you make of the latest week
in america post dnc pre-rnc
uh and we'll be back in just a couple of
minutes the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do
is take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
nicholas breiter and peter sue
say thank you to nicholas and peter also
want to say thanks to stephanie
christoph who's today's long time
sustaining member of the day
stephanie's been a member you guessed it
almost five years
and is a very special person i invite
you to join
these great people grab a membership at
joinpacman.com
let's go to the phone lines at
617-830-4750
starting today with our caller from the
270 area code caller from 270. what's
your name where are you calling from
western kentucky you said damon from
western kentucky go ahead yes sir
um well i was just calling um first of
all i want to point out
i'm sorry i'm kind of nervous here
that's okay biden and harris
are not my first choice at all okay i
think the worst
worst you could have gotten that would
have been biden klovachar however
after a little bit of agonizing i
decided i am voting biden just because
even though i'm in kentucky and i think
if i voted third party it wouldn't
matter much anyways i want to see trump
lose big in the popular vote just so he
can't say oh this was rigged i think
there really needs to be a great big
coalition
rejecting him i agree i i mentioned this
last week in that we have to run up the
score obviously this is an electoral
college contest
but given that we anticipate donald
trump might
either try to challenge the results or
claim it was rigged or whatever
a bigger margin in the popular vote is
better than a smaller margin so i agree
with you
oh exactly i didn't want to say as you
know more gets pragmatic left with
leaning people
i do think one way we can screw up is we
don't need to shame people
yes feel different we need to explain to
them
this and the best description i ever
heard and forgiven going on too long
make this quick
there was a left-wing youtuber who said
if you believe in what bernie and what
aoc stand for
and you look at the the amount of work
they put in
and what they fought for if you think oh
we're just going to
punt this and let trump get it because
we're not get the right president
you're pretty much helping destroy
everything they work for because i don't
think biden
is necessarily going to become
progressive when he gets elected
but it's going to be a lot easier to
convince him and harris
to go for medicare for all and go for
free college and legalizing marijuana if
it is trump and i think we have to
understand that and we have to look at
the down ballot votes and we have to
look at this as a way of for lack of a
better term helping to
infiltrate the democratic party you know
that sounds really
machiavellian no but it makes sense and
i think
no matt you you and i don't think we're
going to get medicare for all because
not because of biden
but because most democratic senators
don't even support it but that's a
that's a specific thing you're
completely right that
with trump we get zero percent of what
bernie wanted
and with biden we probably definitely
get
10 and are in a position to get another
50
i mean listen it's just numbers right
and so the only real argument would be
i want to destroy the entire system to
build it back up in the image that i
value
but there's no historical example that
tells us that's how change happens so i
would reject it on historical grounds
but you and i think are on the same page
of course and one more thing and then
i'll stop but i
started with cornell west and i think
the best thing he said
is he said basically implied he's going
to vote for biden and
harris but he said that does not mean i
endorse them that does not mean that i'm
not going to criticize them and i think
we need to be able
to point out when they do something
wrong just like i remember when you're
you're a big bernie supporter but when
bernie did something you thought was the
wrong thing
you would not pay to say it
right uh yeah i mean listen uh all that
voting for one person over another means
is you think you're better than that
other person do you think they are
better than that other person that's all
i mean it doesn't mean anything else and
then we go and and we
do do the work all right my friend thank
you for the call i appreciate it
we are taking calls at 617-830-4750
let's go next to ronald reagan who is on
the line today
ronald what's going on oh
hey david how's it going good how are
you
good i wanted to say um i really
appreciated your tone
uh the tone of your show i think that
you
um are taking the threat of
of what's uh what we're staring down uh
very seriously and which threat is that
appreciate that
well what's coming uh in november
and what could come in another four
years if we don't
uh do the right thing got it um
yeah i mean i think there's a lot of
naval gazing on the left and sort of
like
you know like there's a time and a place
i feel like for
not that i'm some dnc lackey or anything
like that
but um it's just really frustrating i
think to
to see people um treating this as sort
of like
um situation normal and it's not um
i i do want to suggest um i don't know
if
if it's possible to line up a week of
shows or something like that where
you break down sort of like the
battleground states and their electoral
systems
and who's in charge and what those
states
what the voting should look like because
i do think
on election night and that time period
afterwards like
we're likely to see some irregularities
and
and it would be good if people are
prepared for that
i think that that is good you know i i
think to be totally transparent i think
a week of shows
listing state voting systems would be
pretty bad i don't i don't think my
audience would appreciate that
two weeks would be even worse that would
be twice as bad but
what i will continue to do is to let
people know where it is that they can
find out
in their state where can you early vote
when can you start early voting what's
the process for voting absentee can you
drop off your absentee ballot that i
will keep giving people the resources to
figure that out but i'm not going to do
two weeks of shows on that unfortunately
well all right yeah we've come to a
compromise
i'm glad that we've done that fair uh
keep keep up the good work
and uh one of my good friends who i mean
look
you don't have to put this on your show
if you don't want to but uh
who i met literally through the majority
report
he's now he's now a david pakman member
and like a big fan of your show
that doesn't mean so that's huge so um
you know i don't want you to think it's
all um
antagonistic coming from the ray gun
i love it i love it all right my friend
thank you for the call
david all right we'll see it there's
ronald reagan not reagan like the
president
ray gun like a ray like a cathode ray
gun
as if if you can imagine that okay let's
go next to our caller
from the six one four area code who's
finding themselves on the line today
from six
one four hi david uh this is uh
from paolo ohio ulaschini
okay i'm realizing when you send super
chats i've been mispronouncing your name
but i appreciate that now
no it's okay i can't yeah that's cool
that you remember that
um but um i just have a i have a
question
um for like the longer but the long run
of the progressive party so i i recently
saw a clip from the kyle kowinski show
where he talks about
um you know he gave his input that if
the if
the left and progressives want to enact
um progressive policies um they would
have to take over
the the democratic party because we're
obviously in a two-party system
and i was just wondering what your what
your view was on that like
do you think that an overrunning of the
of the democratic party is the way to go
or do you think a third party is an
option so that you know the lesser of
two evils argument doesn't really
exist anymore so i was just wondering
what you thought about that listen you
really have to work both angles at the
same time
obviously in an ideal system we wouldn't
have a two-party system where if you're
not a democrat or a republican at least
at everything other than a local level
you essentially have no power even the
few independents in the senate caucus
with the democrats in this case it's
bernie and angus king so
i would be working to try to change
campaign finance and how elections are
structured which are really the two big
issues that we need to change if a third
party is ever going to have a shot but
simultaneously if you only do that
and you don't infiltrate the democratic
party at all
you could lose 5 10 20 100 years i mean
who knows how long that first process is
going to take so you need to be doing
both you've got to be able to walk and
chew gum at the same time
right yeah yeah absolutely i mean i just
uh i always thought that the answer was
somewhere in the middle and you don't
have to kind of
go to one side or the other so yeah i
appreciate that thank you so much david
thanks for everything you do
all right thank you for the call great
to hear from you uh
oh you know what let's do this i'm gonna
put this furious trumpist jimmy from
philly we agreed he would call in
because
he has some insane situation going on
that i want to hear about i hope we're
able to talk about it rationally
jimmy are you there my friend yeah i'm
here
okay so i want jimmy
let me see if i can set this up jimmy
and then i'll start getting
your input on it jimmy contacted me
saying he had
a gofundme and i
looked at it and it looks as though
jimmy complained to me that someone
stole his trump lawn signs
but then in the gofundme it looks like
jimmy's raising money for legal fees
because he got arrested so jimmy explain
what happened
okay so i'm sitting uh two day
the day before someone stole two of my
trump signs
okay i reported them that morning
someone stole another one
reported that one too okay now hold on
jimmy jimmy jimmy i want
if we're going to do this we got to make
sure we have the details clear so
i want to make sure we understand you
you awoke and looked outside
your trump signs were gone and you
called the police and said i'm reporting
the theft of my trump sign is that what
you mean by i reported it
yes okay good got it yeah they came out
the first time and then when i called
the next morning and said i will just
add it to the report got it yeah thanks
officer
but anyway so i sit out there and i have
a few drinks and i'm basically guarding
my signs you know and uh
poor black young black men and i never
felt menaced
david they were having a ball they were
gleeful
they ran onto the lawn so quickly i
didn't even have time to stand up
they grabbed four signs they ran into
their car and they drove around the
block three times
fyd f trump then
they're stopped at the light and i ran
after them
to stop the car get my you know i was
out of my mind you know
so some uh trump peyton uh person
didn't take a video of that but they
took a video of me running down the
street like a lunatic
okay so jimmy let's pause let's pause
because i don't want to miss a second of
this idiocy and i want my audience to
fully understand it
this is now separate from the initial
the incidents you reported you're out on
your lawn having a beer
and four men who you believe to be black
and find their race relevant
they steal your lawn signs and drive
away but then they're circling the block
is that correct
yes they're circling to the block
screaming f whitey
uh f trump okay and then you believe in
them
uh pretty good vision i do wear glasses
but
and then jimmy and then so you run after
the car
you run out into the street and run
after the car
yeah yeah okay and obviously a car is
faster obviously a car is faster than a
person so does the car out there
they were stopped at the light okay less
than half a block away
okay okay so i went after the car they
get out of the car now they could have
beat me up
okay but they had never had the
intention they were just
20 something some 20 somethings out
just trying to mess with mess with kid
you know they were like laughing and
they chased me back to my house
right so the cops come so the cop says
to me listen jimmy
he says i understand about the trump
signs
you're allowed to be drunk on your
property but the moment
you step off your property probably
drunk and i have to arrest you
okay now jimmy hold on i want to commend
you now that you're speaking more
quietly
your audio is coming through so much
more nicely so let's keep the quiet
voice now here's the one detail you
skipped over
you claim that these four men chased you
back to your house
and then the police show up
what were these four guys doing then did
they run away while
they had left i mean i guess the cops
came maybe five minutes later
okay and the cop says you can be drunk
on your property but once you leave your
property it's public intoxication
yes and he said and because i have a
video he said if i didn't have the video
i wouldn't lock you up he's like but i
have a video
it's you and uh you gotta go so i put my
hands behind my back i give no static
so you were you were arrested for public
and toxic
if i understand correctly jeremy hold on
correct you were arrested
for public intoxication for chasing a
car
full of men who had stolen your trump
sign
in your neighborhood correct okay
correct so it gets better so they bring
me to the police station
and the intake top says look i blew the
breathalyzer they said you're not that
big
usually when we get a call for the
public dunking we're expecting
holy hell but we're not going to cuff
you to the chair
don't act up which i didn't he hands me
cell phone and he says
call a friend as soon as they come you
can go i call three people nobody's
answering he says look
you can sit there for an hour and call
just keep calling people yeah so i call
my old boss recently
jimmy i'll be there in 12 minutes one
hour goes by
two hours goes by three hours goes by
i scream under the cell door
the protocol is to test me you can't
hold me here all night just because you
want to
so they come and test me and they say
you're just blowing under the legal
limit
we're going to give you a ride home gee
thanks
so i called my lawyer and he said jimmy
they got you
basically it's an unfortunate situation
uh you know he said uh
i could probably bring into the
mitigation that signs were stolen before
and you know that they you know were
riding around the block pointing you
you weren't thinking correctly you said
but by law yeah you are getting he said
and he said jimmy i'm going to probably
hit you for 1500 you're probably going
to lose then you're going to probably
have to pay the fine too
right and the serge the sarge stole me
he said look jimmy the finest two three
hundred
it would go for me you know
because initially i was trying to raise
fifteen hundred right okay jimmy
but i we we're just all i need to kind
of manage this a little bit because it's
we're just
all over the place so as it stands right
now
it it sounds like you're saying you're
not going to hire a lawyer for 1500
because public intoxication it's not
like you're going to go to prison or
jail you're going to owe a few hundred
bucks is that right
right it's a fine of probably two to
three hundred let's face it david
1500 for a lawyer who's telling me i'll
probably lose and this lawyer has never
lost a case for me i mean he's a bad boy
i mean i i protested by the lawyers
or banks i've been arrested for
protesting many times i beat the case
every time
but anyway yeah i'd have to throw 15 in
him probably two or three more for a
fine and lose a day's work
right so the smart thing to do is take
it on the chin
and pay the fine do you think the
smarter thing to do would be
not to drunkenly chase after people in
your neighborhood is that smarter
well the smart thing to do would be not
to go on my lawn and steal my property
right but i'm talking about you can only
control your actions right you can't
control those of others
this is true this is true but hear me
out david no but here hold on jimmy i i
want to
get keep on the core part so in our
conversations
you've revealed that you were previously
arrested for domestic violence which is
why you don't
see your daughter regularly and now
you've been arrested for public
that's not true i don't see my daughter
regularly because her mother has
poisoned
her against me i've seen my daughter for
years after that incident took her to uh
every amusement park under the sun
bought the uh you know you buy the 100
wristband at six flags and you go on the
ride twice and
all that five hundred dollars i would
spend every time i took the kid out
every sunday
all right jimmy listen i um
yeah i mean you know that you and i
don't agree on politics i reject your
your
racist xenophobic homophobic views but
it sounds like you're in a tough spot so
i'm sorry to hear that
david david i'm far from a racist and
let me explain to you how bad this
country's gone and it's a very short
story
no no but jimmy jimmy i think you you've
i've i told you i would go to you if you
called in
we've given you about twice the time
most callers get so let's put a pause on
it
there i think the audience gets the
story now and
i think we've done enough for one day
jimmy
okay but i just want to tell you that
the hard baster is
killing you david i don't know what that
is is that a relative of yours he's
telling you
pac-man fever
david pakman power enema
david he's killing you he's killing you
this is your
friend and some of you some of your uh
leftist compatriots come on to my
channel and they are respectful
oh my god all right there's just i have
to cut it because there's just no ending
it
okay um we're gonna go to a quick break
and then right back to the phone line so
don't hang up if you are holding
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpacman.com
that's
join p a pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lowercase
become a member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay now that we've had a chance to sort
of calm down from that
wild jimmy from philly call let's go
back to the phone lines at 617-830-4750
and see what's on people's minds
starting with our caller from the 928
area code who is calling today from 928
hey david this is sean hey sean what's
going on
um i'm just curious why is no one
talking about
um so i know it's a law that says
election day has to be
the second tuesday or whatever well i
think the way it's technically it's the
first
tuesday after the first monday so it
couldn't be the first of the month i
guess is the idea
why why is no one talking about since
that's a law why don't they just
extend it like i've always questioned
why it's not on a weekend anyway
so why don't they talk about making it
you know
the week instead of just one day okay
well people
people who talk about changing people do
talk about either making election day a
federal
holiday although it's unclear the net
benefit of that because
a lot of people work on holidays anyway
it would just kind of like change who's
able to vote there's a discussion about
voting on the we
all of these things have been discussed
but it's very difficult to do it
certainly isn't going to happen between
now and november but
is there some particular reason why you
think this time around it should be done
well because of the pandemic right you
could spread out you could say
you know if you have a last name a to d
got it on tuesday
whatever so the easier way to do it
legally would be instead of extending
voting to multiple days
you would just start every day so
right now early voting in states that
have it it's usually only a few polling
places and it's limited hours the way to
do what you're suggesting
i think sean would be on october 27th we
say
polls open today and they will be open
through the end of november 3rd and give
right so start with
a full day early voting in all polling
places
that would probably be the simplest way
to do it legally and logistically
right so instead of this stupid argument
about mailing
ballots and fraud that's not going to
happen why don't the states just start
talking about that i haven't heard
anything about that yeah i mean it's not
being discussed because i just don't
think
most governors are going to do it and
logistically to keep polling places you
know
people volunteer months ahead of time to
do poll work
on one day if you're gonna say we're now
gonna have seven days of poll work
i it is a logistical nightmare and i get
why it's not being discussed but as an
idea i think it's a good one
all right well you don't think it's
going to happen ever
that we send uh election data more than
one day
i don't think it's going to happen this
year but i'm open to it you know who can
say what will happen in the future
right so basically democrats would have
to get
have two-thirds of the vote right in the
senate in order for that law to actually
pass
well it would probably be easier to do
it at the state level where governor
because governors control early voting
so you don't even have to do it in the
senate
uh okay
all right thank you okay thank you
appreciate it people are thinking that's
good
i like to see that uh let's see here
let's go to our caller from the 731 area
code who's calling today from 731
hey david is that me yes it is who's
this
this is david from jackson tennessee
love it what's going on
uh so i was watching a clip from the
same cg
show the other day and he made a comment
that i took
slight issue with and i was wondering if
i could get your opinion on it sure i
mean i'm gonna have to take your word
that you're
you're quoting it accurately but go
ahead
uh basically he was talking about
some right-wing commentator i can't
remember the name of
and he said when it comes to right-wing
commentators it's essentially
you sometimes need to ask the question
is this person
evil or stupid or most of the time
basically that i agree with you
and well i don't know
i can understand where he's coming from
because i look at a guy like
michael knowles for example i think he
can intentionally
misrepresent certain things and i could
see why he would see
someone like that as evil or you can
look at
like matt walsh also in the daily wire
and i could see why you think he's maybe
less than intelligent
but i honestly think ben shapiro i think
he's
very intelligent and i think that he
you know i don't think that he's
actually trying to misdirect his
audience
i think he believes that conservative
economics is the way to go
and i think it's kind of unfair to
refer to someone like him as evil well
so maybe stupid is a pejorative but if
he really believes conservative
right-wing
economics is the way to go and
we know that it's not from having
you know 120 150 180 years
of evidence to suggest that it we don't
have to say that he's stupid but we
could say he's wrong on the facts right
like if we were able to say
shapiro's factually wrong that tax cuts
for the rich stimulate the economy
he doesn't have to be evil and stupid is
a bit of an ad hominem but we could say
he's just wrong
right could we call it ignorance
yeah i would say that's fine okay so i
think maybe stupid is too pejorative
but what we're talking about is
ignorance to the facts and i think in
that sense it's sort of getting to
what's going on
yeah it just it bothered me a little bit
just because like i said i'm from
tennessee
yeah and even though i'm a progressive
i've
tons of friends and family who are
conservative and
my dad is probably the smartest person i
personally know and he's
a massive ronald reagan fan and all that
but then
it baffles me that he's so intelligent
and he still believes it but
i think my dad's a great guy and he's
very smart so well he
he may he very well may be but is it
possible that because of your dad's
ideology
he may be selectively ignoring certain
facts in order to
keep his ideology neat and tidy
yeah wouldn't make him a bad person
yeah i think i see what you're saying
but
honestly i think everybody does that a
little bit i guess you could say
conservatives do that more
but i think that's just human nature it
is no there's no denying that that i
agree with
yeah but anyway that was just i was
wondering what you thought about that i
wasn't a big fan of that comment but
i could see where he was coming from and
i don't know it sounds like you don't
like the tone but you mostly agree with
the substance
yeah i guess so yeah all right my friend
thank you for the call i appreciate it
david in tennessee
wow a lot happening on the phone lines
today let's go next to our caller from
the eight
five zero area code who's calling today
from eight five zero
uh hi david this is luke luke what can i
do for you
uh my questions about uh bill clinton's
speech last night from the uh
democratic national convention yes a
couple nights ago because this is friday
remember
oh gotcha gotcha i was wondering what
you thought about the lighting
of the room you know the lighting was
amazing actually i mentioned this during
the live stream
it was some of the most pristine
lighting that i've seen
and it almost looked green screen like
they got it wasn't head on right one
side of his face
was just just softly brighter than the
other side
it had depth it had size i mean it was
you know the gaffers
and the grips deserve a round of
congratulations bill
bill clinton's lighting was amazing
awesome a quick question and a comment
too if you don't mind
sure okay um i was turned off to
politics when the whole merrick garland
thing happened in the last year of uh
obama's presidency right and um
i was thrown back in once with the rise
of trump like it's
even surreal to this day so i've been
looking for
sort of political commentators who are
well reasoned in their arguments uh
they're not tied down to like tribalism
or anything like that
um uh very fair and reasonable political
commentators i lean less personally
but um that's what i'm looking for your
appearances on the joe rogan podcast
uh brought me to you and um i was
wondering if you can recommend
um anyone who sort of meets that
criteria that you do
uh this sort of uh well-reasoned
eloquent
um uh political commentators
i i've been recently put on to um i
think his name is uh
uh destiny um oh you mean um
you mean stephen kenneth destiny bonnell
ii
ah there we go but um uh
him you is there anyone else you can
recommend because i'm fairly new to
your show and uh your youtube channel
and stuff like that
you know it's really just me i can't i
can really just recommend more of my own
show
unfortunately i could i wouldn't no i
mean listen here's the thing
to be honest i'm the wrong person to ask
because i don't even i barely know who's
out there like there's a bunch of people
who are my friends who do this stuff but
i'm actually
i was talking to lance of the serfs
recently
he knows the landscape of the
commentators on left and right so we're
thinking of doing a collaboration soon
where he's sort of going to expose me to
the good and bad including the
underbelly of of
right-wing commentary and stuff like
that i really would not be able to say
there's so many people out there now
doing their thing
but i just don't do any watching of
content like mine as a personal i just
get enough of this stuff where i want to
disconnect
and i don't i watch you know chess
gardening instruction on youtube i just
really don't know i don't know
awesome all right well thanks anyway but
um just one last comment if you don't
mind
yeah uh your appearances on the
i think his name is jessie lee peterson
yes that's gotta be
the funniest stuff i've ever seen in my
life thank you
thank you i would someday after the
pandemic hopefully i can be back on with
him
it would be incredible uh thanks for
taking my call david all right my friend
thank you i appreciate it uh
great to hear from luke there um that is
going to do it for calls today
much better sound today during the calls
we will take calls again the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media
and you can contribute any amount you
want on patreon
as little as one dollar per month plus
you can get the daily
bonus show world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv
show by making those pledges at
patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv or even
listen on the radio
patreon.com slash david pakman show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get right into audience
questions the first one
uh is about mike pence david would
replacing mike pence help
donald trump get reelected would it help
him in the polls
so it's extremely unlikely that
replacing pence would help trump
and it has the serious potential to hurt
donald trump and there's a few things
you have to understand about vp picks
vp picks um the the the situation the
risk reward with the vice presidential
pick
is asymmetrical and what i mean by that
is a
bad vp pick can hurt you much more than
a good vp pick
can help you because a good vp pick
essentially causes no drama
causes no scandals stays out of the way
is a reasonably okay debater so that in
the
not particularly a highly viewed vice
presidential debate
they hold their own and they essentially
just they know the talking points they
don't get hugely embarrassed
you know sarah palin uh uh in her vp
debate
really didn't do well but it still
didn't really hurt mccain palin that
much i mean
it already wasn't going particularly
well for them but
on the other hand if you have a great vp
they don't do that much for you and so
that's why
the ac asymmetrical nature to me would
suggest that
unless pence is a problem for trump
it's risky to replace him and you also
have to remember
replacing your vp is a sign that
something is wrong
the the very news of replacing the vp if
trump were to do it
even if he takes pence and replaces him
with someone like equally okay
um that could be a wash but the news
that there's
chaos and disorganization with you know
we're days before the convention at this
point the republican national convention
that could actually hurt donald trump
and
um there if we look at pence
specifically
you could also make the case that he's
complementary to trump in some way
i know that trump now pretends to be
religious and he says when he was in his
late 60s
he stopped being pro-choice and now he's
against abortion
and all of this you know he reads the
bible i don't believe any of it but to
the extent that anybody does or doesn't
believe it
mike pence's evangelical credentials
probably help
trump in some key states with the
evangelical base which um
again white evangelicals we'll talk
about this later actually white
evangelicals tend to vote republican
would they be turned off from trump if
pence wasn't there
i don't know so to me um
a bad vp can really be a problem whereas
a good vp
just kind of keeps chugging along pence
in terms of demographics could actually
be good for trump
and a replacement itself could signal
trouble
and could backfire now the one thing i
am
interested in that's that's maybe a
little bit different this time around
is we are going to have um a democratic
female vp candidate debating
a white evangelical older male
republican
in the vp debate now if you think back
to
palin uh versus biden back in 2008
uh sarah palin is just not
uh as quick or or well versed in policy
or skilled at debating as is kamala
harris
but the dynamics were where you had
the democratic white male
debating against the younger republican
woman and that is a different dynamic
particularly in these times where
xenophobia is now welcomed into the open
by the presidency of donald trump the
the
racist right-wingers are more willing
than ever to say the things that they
were probably always thinking etc
i am interested in what the sort of
sidebar around
the debate what is going to be the
right-wing coverage how are they going
to deal with kamala harris if birther
2.0
is any sign the the early questions
about is kamal harris actually eligible
to be vp
um it could get very very ugly with a
woman of color on the democratic side
debating
evangelical white republican mike pence
that's in september uh actually no i
believe that the vp debate is not even
until october so we have some time
unless it gets canceled but i think
that's going to be interesting but
should trump replace pep pence probably
not
probably not hey david why do most white
people vote for republicans
this is uh this is a complex question
that requires a lot of different
um exploration and the answer is not
um because white people are merely
racist
and they vote for republicans that
that's not if that's what you believe
it's overly simplistic there are of
course elements of racism
uh but that's really not what this is
about so it is true that when you
look at current polling and you slice
and dice it demographically by age by
race
by income you know all these different
things by education donald trump is
winning among men by not not by a huge
margin donald trump is winning among
white
voters and donald trump is winning among
uneducated voters the more education you
have the more likely
you are to support joe biden the answer
to a lot of the white
support for republicans actually is
religion and i want people to be very
very carefully
understanding what it is that i'm saying
here white
evangelicals overwhelmingly vote for
republicans
white non-evangelicals are pretty split
between the democratic and the
republican party so to say it another
way
were it not for white evangelicals
the republican party would not have the
advantage it has
among white voters and this is why you
might
see american politics and you say
there's more support for abortion today
than there has been at any time since
roe v wade
uh and yet they st the republicans still
kowtow to being against abortion
and they still uh try to play you know
they trump speaking at the march for
life and all of this different stuff
the reason why is that they are
dependent
on the white evangelical voter not only
for votes but also for
donations evangelicals are just over a
third of white voters
okay so you've got all white voters a
third of white voters are evangelical
they voted for trump roughly four to one
80 to 20.
other white voters went for hillary
56-44 according to exit polls against
trump in 2016.
so when you slice and dice the
electorate you
you start to understand that the
analysis that
white people prefer republicans it's not
really getting at the core of the issue
which in this particular case is
religiosity now
anytime you look at these distinctions
uh
you have to be able to separate
causation versus correlation
okay i don't know exactly how that
affects
the the white voter element of it but
for example
with education you see that people
without a college degree
are the most likely educationally to be
voting for trump
people with a college degree support joe
biden by by a pretty big margin
people with a postgraduate degree
support joe biden by an even higher
margin the more education you have the
more likely you are to support biden
over trump
i actually believe that is causal i
think that
education as a process makes you less
likely to be bamboozled by
stupid talking points from trump like i
know all about trade and i will fix it
the more educated you are the more
likely you are to realize trump knows
nothing about trade and he's not going
to fix it and you shouldn't fall for it
so
that is causal to me with some of these
other things
religion race whatever
i think that we have to explore whether
the correlations have a causal component
that's sort of not
really what we were taking head on but
that's the situation
yes white voters support republicans but
were it not for white evangelicals
that support would be very much in
question david there's a lot of
discussion about
income inequality if we accept that it's
a problem
how can we actually fix it okay this is
a good question
um let's not debate whether income
inequality is a problem
let's accept that it is and that's not
what this segment is about
we can talk about whether it's a problem
in another segment i believe that it is
and i've outlined why
many times the most important
fact to realize about fixing income
inequality
is that we don't need to come up with
anything
new we we have essentially all the ideas
we need
to deal with income inequality now to be
very clear
i don't believe that we need perfect
distribution of income
perfect distribution equality of
outcomes so to speak
is not naturally occurring anywhere i
don't believe it would be good to force
it
i'm not a socialist i don't believe
there would be any reasonable
reasonable expectation that everybody
has the same amount of money what i do
think as a social democrat though is
the bottom should be lifted there should
be a safety net that says we're not
going to allow people to
fall below this level and then at the
top
you should have more restrictions about
okay if we say
billionaires are okay are
multi-billionaires
turbo billionaires what at what point do
we want to be saying
now is when you've got to really be
redistributing it's a gray area
different people would put it at a
different
different spot we have all of the
different
tools but the problem is getting the
right combination so as an example
should the minimum wage be higher than
it is right now
of course is a 15 minimum wage
nationally going to solve the problem of
inequality
no we need a higher minimum wage exactly
what it should be probably depends on
the state that we're in
but a 15 minimum wage isn't even a
living wage in many states based on cost
of living so
do we need to raise the minimum wage yes
there will be people who come in and say
well
if a higher minimum wage is better why
not just make it 200 an hour
that's not an equilibrium wage anywhere
and that's a red herring don't fall for
it
do we need a more robust social service
system funded by taxes on the very very
rich but that includes
financial transactions and some of these
other ideas yeah
we've got the tools we know what it
would look like there's just no
political will to do it right now
do we need better educational
access regardless of income because one
of the great equalizers is
education and unfortunately in our
society
yes there are scholarships yes we know
about all that stuff
but the reality is um there is very low
income
mobility in the united states and part
of that is because there is not
widespread
good education that is accessible to
people who start off in an economically
disadvantaged position
trade is part of it you know trump talks
about trade some trade things can be bad
for the middle class
i'll concede that you've got to look at
trade we can look at things like
universal basic income or
a value-added tax and there's pros and
cons to all of these
my point is there are no new tools that
are necessary to deal with income
inequality
but we have to get away from do nothing
and let the markets handle it
because we know that doesn't work we
know that doesn't work
i'm fine as a social democrat letting
markets work to direct resources
in many industries as i've said before i
don't need the government
making all the cell phones or making all
the airplanes but
i sure as hell want the government
involved in regulating those industries
and well-regulated markets where private
industry is manufacturing stuff
i'm fine with certain areas need to be
taken out of that
health care education
you could argue that some basic level of
housing
should be taken out of that it's a
debate in the gray area but we've got
all the tools
we need to figure out how to put them
together in the right proportions
send in your questions for next week's
audience questions through our website
davidpakman.com
we have a great bonus show for you today
and remember that on august 23rd
the 15th anniversary of the david pakman
show
we will be doing a one-day huge
membership special
it will be based on the theme of 15
years
and you can be notified of it by jumping
on our free newsletter at
davidpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or
listen to an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes you can try blinkist for
free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video